"What if?" We ask ourselves this question
all the time at Carnegie Mellon University.
What if students were immersed in a
collaborative learning environment where
open spaces translate into open ideas?
What if the world's most forward-looking
business school created the education of
the future to prepare the next
generation of leaders to be pioneers of
change in a dynamic global world? What if we unleashed innovation by giving
promising entrepreneurs from every
corner of CMU access to a center that
merges business technology and design?
What if every prospective student, parent,
alum, supporter, partner and visitor could
feel welcomed and wowed as they
experienced the richness of CMU first hand?
What if emerging business executives
harness the latest practices expertise
and coaching to accelerate their growth
and transform industries?
What if students can become global citizens by
connecting with cultures through a
multimedia-rich interactive learning space?
What if educators revolutionized
learning by developing new technologies
and techniques with state of the art
classrooms and teaching innovation studios?
What if every student, every faculty
member, every target had access, had the
inspiration, had the place to create, to
build, to innovate, to accelerate the
convergence of ideas to solve the
world's greatest challenges? "What if?"
Two words that represent the future of how
Carnegie Mellon is empowering tomorrow's
thinkers, innovators and discoverers,
giving them the tools to stretch the
limits of our imagination. Now, as we
celebrate the opening of the Tepper Quad,
we are prepared to go beyond "What if?"
Today we ask, "What next?"